moi si j'ai eu des braseros dit oui oui
à travers une caméra
non non non ça comme ça ouais sur
quelqu'un de connu et ce que tu as
aujourd'hui arrivée sur ce plateau n'ont
pas passé ce plat toi tu m'as marine et
ses pages internet sur ce plateau un
coran il s'appelle comment il s'appelle
antoine elle donne et fait appel à sa
pelle quoi c'est pas ben haim mais non
non c'est tout c'est kelly non c'est
quoi c'est pas isabelle voilà ouais
c'est consulter un sont consultés non
attendez j'ai mis en débat mais c'est
comme ça qui a eu l'idée de leiria
d'audace du nom d'une émission
un jour il m'a fait un compliment
splendide me dis jamais la boîte daffy
duck
c'était simplement une très belle free
va en tout cas je voyais non mais vous
rattrapent où je suis sûr que c'est
votre style en mai moi j'adorais le père
j'adore le fils et qui adore qu'est-ce
qui n'alerte à voir comment tu as dit
avant ça va possiblement possible faut
faire un choix
non non ça va pas être possible c'était
balancer sérieusement qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'ils rendent une fois en fuite
aujourd'hui
voilà
faire pendant l'émission
vous connaissiez doc gynéco oui bien sûr
ça us c'est un très bon acteur nous
attend on se connaît très bien et puis
me parlent à l'oreille de tout le temps
si vous propose à boire ne